look there's when we actually met
and then there's like the months
preceding that where i felt like i knew
you because no one could speak to me
without saying your name is that true
yeah so you and we'll get i want to get
into you know you growing up in cassidy
freeman as a young girl what was going
on and how all that happened because
that's kind of like i want to i want to
hear the story i want to know like what
you were like and all this stuff but
you and look we can get into the small
stuff now but like we met because your
old agent i don't think she's your agent
anymore
schmidt schmidt
she's still your agent she's not your
agent but she called me and said hey
you know my my uh client um
cassidy freeman is taking over for your
role she didn't say it like that she
just said you know that she's a new
character on smallville and you've left
and you know she'd like to you know i'd
love if you just have a chat with her so
i remember that and i remember we had a
chat
do you remember what the chat
consisted of
i don't i do
i know i want you to
bless you ryan i was really stoned a lot
that time in my life you were really
stoned
what
were you a pot smoker you don't appear
to be a pot smoker
how what does a pot smoker appear to be
like
you know someone who appears to be
stoned
you never like you came across you just
always seem like very professional very
with it not that you're not not that pot
smokers can't be with it i'm just saying
i didn't know thank you tell me what the
conversation was about let's let's leave
my drug use to it i think we'll get into
your drug use and your
real we will sincerely uh i you know i
think it was just like what can i expect
you know i'm going up to vancouver to
shoot this and i said listen it's the
hardest job in the world is stepping in
as a guest star
that's the hardest thing you can do
is go on to a television series that's
already established and say hey here i
am i'm cassidy freeman and i'm taking
over for michael rosenbaum sort of and
i'm playing his sister that's how it was
always yeah that's how it was always
described and i just said hey the crew
is great and the cast is great they're
going to be really warm to you
and
but i was lying
because uh no i wasn't i was lying but
what was your experience like
you know do you remember like
were you nervous you had to have been
nervous
absolutely i was nervous i had literally
done one guest star and one pilot before
booking that in my life that's it
that's it
so i had no idea and the and the pilot
that i've done before
becoming test mercer was um
another pilot for the cw that i did with
justin hartley
so i weirdly had a touchstone coming
with me the fact that he was coming on
as a series rag
with me um
and
it was terrifying also weirdly moving to
canada was difficult uh like in us in
the world of cell phones and rents and
i was still so young like i didn't know
how old were you
how old are you it's 20 24
24 i think i started smalling when i was
26 or 27.
that's crazy
i mean you are a kid still you're a kid
and now you're thrusted up
into canada
vancouver where it rains 90 of the time
and you're playing this character in the
seas established show and starting
season eight
yeah
yeah everyone was really nice to me you
know the but it did feel very lonely
sometimes because um you know tom's
awesome but he's a pretty private person